schnallen sie sich besser an denn es
erwarten sie haar sträubende aufnahmen
ob reingefahren oder platt gemacht
haarscharf vorbei
oder mittenrein
kleine kameras auf dem armaturenbrett
sogenannte des camps zeichnen gnadenlos
alles auf
in vielen ländern boomt der markt für
base camps die aufnahmen sollen bei
unfällen als beweismittel dienen und vor
betrügern schützen die abkassieren
wollen
kein wunder also dass immer mehr
verblüffende videoclips im umlauf sind
halten sie sich gut fest wir starten
unsere reise um die welt mit bildern die
ihnen garantiert den atem rauben werden
los geht's das sind die spektakulärsten
des camps und keine sorge
niemand wird hier ernsthaft verletzt
auch wenn es manchmal knapp wird
richtig knapp
dieses mal nasse straßen und grandiose
rutschpartie
fußgänger die dem tod von der schippe
springen und eine runde boxen biker
gegen autofahrer wer gewinnt
[Applaus]
achtung rutschgefahr
regen und nassen straßen machen das
autofahren weder leichter noch sicherer
man sieht schlechter
und auch die sache mit dem lenken
bremsen und der allgemeinen stabilität
kommt an ihre grenzen
also fahren sie lieber langsam und
bremsen sie möglichst nicht zu abrupt
und halten sie einen angemessenen
sicherheitsabstand ein
wer in kritischen situationen richtig
reagiert hat die besten chancen nicht in
der notaufnahme zu landen
eigentlich sind die autofahrer in moskau
schlechtes wetter gewohnt aber selbst
leichter regen stellt die fahrkünste
mancher auf die probe schon 2 mm wasser
auf der straße können zu aquaplaning
führen wenn das profil der reifen das
wasser nicht ableiten kann verlieren sie
die haftung komplett
[Applaus]
liebesgrüße aus moskau
sowieso schon mieser sicht schlamm auf
der straße und spritzwasser von diesem
lkw so macht autofahren wenig spaß wenn
dann noch der gegenverkehr plötzlich
ausscherte
wäre man wahrscheinlich lieber zug
gefahren
regen und plötzlicher frost haben diese
schnellstraße in eine schlittschuhbahn
verwandelt
bei dem aufprall
wird dieser nicht angeschnallte insasse
aus dem wagen geschleudert
wie ein eishockey puck schießt er über
die spiegelglatte straße zum glück kommt
er mit ein paar schrammen davon
ähnliches szenario aber noch heftiger
der lkw schleuderte in die leitplanke
fahrer und beifahrer werden aus dem
führerhaus katapultiert
dann drehen sie noch ein paar pirouetten
schnallt euch lieber an jungs
nasse straße kurz abgebremst und schon
ist der wagen außer kontrolle
er kommt zum stehen aber ein denkbar
ungünstiger position mitten im weg der
lkw fahrer versucht auszuweichen
immerhin ist er nicht in das auto
gekracht aber die autobahn ist in den
nächsten paar stunden wohl eher ein
parkplatz
wolkenbruchartiger regen man kann kaum
noch was sehen lassen sie sich nicht von
den scheibenwischern und den sanften
klängen der musik einlullen
nicht einschlafen
[Musik]
weg von der straße
fußgänger sind die schwächsten
verkehrsteilnehmer
ständig hakt jemand auf ihnen herum
vögel und schräge vögel
das risiko im straßenverkehr zu sterben
ist bei fußgängern anderthalb mal so
hoch wie bei pkw insassen
in 88 prozent der fälle sind sie nicht
selber schuld also immer den verkehr im
blick haben auf der straße
und auf den bürgersteigen
zebrastreifen und ampeln sind nicht nur
zur dekoration dar
[Musik]
wer sie ignoriert
gehört aus dem verkehr gezogen
[Musik]
was tut man nicht alles um seinen
kindern einzubläuen dass sie nach links
und rechts schauen müssen bevor sie über
die straße gehen oder in england nach
rechts und dann nach links
[Musik]
und dann haben sie als erwachsene alles
vergessen und latschen verträumt auf die
straße
wäre fast ins auge gegangen als
fußgänger sollte man den verkehr am
besten nie aus den augen lassen
auch sowas kann vorkommen ein auto rammt
ein anderes
und schiebt es direkt in die richtung
des fußgängers
[Musik]
wurzeln schlagen wäre da keine gute idee
achtung bei zebrastreifen verlassen sie
sich nicht darauf dass jedes auto anhält
dieser fahrer denkt nicht daran
anzuhalten und fährt eine frau an
zum glück trägt sie nur leichte
verletzungen davon
dafür kommt der mann vor den richter
london hier ist immer viel verkehr und
alle leute sind grundsätzlich in eile
wenn sie schon einfach über die straße
rennen ziehen sie es wenigstens durch
das rad ist hinüber aber wenigstens hat
es das handy überlebt sonst wäre es
wirklich tragisch
vor allem teenager gucken beim laufen
ständig auf ihr smartphone
wir wissen nicht in welcher virtuellen
realität diese kids unterwegs waren aber
der truck hat sie schlagartig in die
reale realität zurückgeholt
knöchel verstaucht aber immerhin noch
unter uns glück gehabt
derzeitig
im verkehr kochen die emotionen oft hoch
bis zum verlust jeglicher manieren
benehmen sie sich bitte nicht wie ein
neandertaler wenn sie das nächste mal
geschnitten
oder aggressiv angehupt werden lehnen
sie sich einfach zurück
erkennen sie die ironie der situation
und vergessen sie es einfach
in deutschland sind über 45 millionen
autos unterwegs und es gibt über 70
millionen fahrräder
leider verstehen sich autofahrer und
fahrradfahrer auf der straße nicht immer
so gut
die fronten sind eher verhärtet
das kann doch youtube und zur polizei
wow hab solche angst es ist nie gut
einen wutbürger zu provozieren
verfluchte scheiße was soll das was
glaubst du eigentlich wer du bist
ich bin radfahrer verpiss dich stillzeit
auf youtube das bringt alles nichts
am besten einfach weiterfahren
[Musik]
motorradfahrer mögen es gar nicht wenn
man ihren helm anfasst finger weg von
meinem helm oder ich ziehe den scheitel
sie mögen es auch nicht um geschubst zu
werden
darauf gibt es nur eine antwort helm ab
jetzt fliegen die vorstände
auto gegen motorrad fahrer wer wird
diesen kampf gewinnen
[Musik]
runde eins geht an den biker für den
tritt bekommt er aber einen punktabzug
runde zwei ein flinker kinnhaken und
schon ist das ganze vorbei
in wirklichkeit gibt es ja keinen
gewinner außer vielleicht uns die
zuschauer
wenn sich zwei sturköpfe auf engerstraße
gegenüberstehen kann das eine weile
dauern keiner will nachgeben keiner
fährt zur seite absolut kindisch und
dann wird es noch kindisch
wenn sie solche impulse bei sich spüren
[Musik]
fahren sie bitte direkt in die nächste
klapsmühle
[Musik]
manche tiere haben sich den menschen
erstaunlich gut angepasst wie es scheint
haben unsere permanenten zankereien im
straßenverkehr auf diese murmeltiere
abgefärbt
[Musik]
da geht es ganz schön zur sache ist dass
jetzt boxen oder mixed martial arts und
was soll denn das
knutschen die vielleicht sollten wir uns
von den tieren eine scheibe abschneiden
und schon ist die sache erledigt
was ist denn da los
heute wird nichts mehr für die ewigkeit
gebaut schade dass das kein
geldtransporter war
gefährliche kreuzung
[Musik]
die meisten unfälle passieren weil
jemand nicht aufpasst
an kreuzungen sollte man besonders acht
geben hier passieren besonders viele
unfälle mit verletzten und toten
also ampeln und vorfahrt schilder
beachten rechtzeitig abbremsen und immer
gut aufpassen
sonst passiert sowas oder sowas oder
sowas oder
sowas
jeder mit einem recht an gesundem
menschenverstand weiß auf einer kreuzung
sollte man keine newton machen
einmal zweimal und ein radfahrer der
gerade großes glück gehabt hat
welche entschuldigung hat der fahrer
parat auch so das gaspedal hat geklemmt
na klar
[Musik]
wenn man über eine kreuzung fährt sollte
man immer vorher nach links und nach
rechts gucken wenn die straße frei ist
kann man entspannt losfahren oder
eben nicht
wer unbedingt ein anderes fahrzeug
rahmen möchte der sollte sich im sinne
der fairness 1 einer ähnlichen
gewichtsklasse aussuchen
na wer gewinnt der lkw oder die
straßenbahn
definitiv nicht der lkw
weil er über eine rote ampel geprägt ist
wird der fahrer zu einer haftstrafe
verdonnert und der führerschein ist auch
weg naja gibt ja noch die straßenbahn
straßenschilder haben durchaus ihren
zweck beim stopp schild soll man nicht
nur kurz stoppen und dann weiterfahren
[Musik]
nein man soll vorher gucken ob jemand
kommt
unglaublich dass die fahrerin das
überlebt hat
hier richtet ein kleinwagen fahrer ein
wahres hellen inferno an
er fährt einfach los direkt vor einen
tanklaster
der dann in flammen aufgeht
die aufräumarbeiten dauern die ganze
nacht
[Musik]
bitte lächeln die kamera läuft
wo wir heutzutage in der öffentlichkeit
rum laufen oder fahren praktisch überall
werden wir gefilmt sei es von
überwachungskameras von handys oder des
camps in den kameras zu entkommen wird
immer schwieriger auch auf der straße
noch nie wurden missglückte manöver und
verstöße gegen recht und gesetz so
flächendeckend eingefangen wie heute
wenn sie also lust kriegen was besonders
riskantes oder gar etwas illegales zu
tun überlegen sie lieber nochmal sonst
sind sie mit ihrer aktion ganz schnell
im fernsehen
bei der produktion dieser sendung ist
uns aufgefallen dass es viele wege gibt
die direkt in die hölle führen und die
meisten liegen in russland
hier sehen wir eine beliebte strategie
für raubüberfälle auf offener straße
zuerst wird das opfer gerammt damit es
stehen bleibt
mit vorgehaltener pistole wird der
unfall gegner genötigt den schaden
sofort zu bezahlen auch die beifahrer
des mannes sehen eher unfreundlich aus
der fahrer bezahlt vernünftigerweise
sofort dank der besch cam dürfen diese
verbrecher bald einen besuch der polizei
erwarten und nicht nur der mode polizei
diese russischen jungs sind liegen
geblieben aber sie haben eine idee
während die fahrgäste einsteigen knotet
einer von ihnen ein seil an den bus
brilliante idee
jetzt nur noch rein springen und lenken
leider klemmt die vordertüren
[Musik]
und dann fährt auch noch just in diesem
moment eine polizeistreife vorbei
vielleicht hätten sie doch lieber in den
bus einsteigen sollen
wer kommt auf die idee einen
polizeiwagen zu grauen dieser mann steht
unter drogen und sucht offenbar den kick
seines lebens in dem er mit blaulicht
durch moskau kopf
[Applaus]
aber dieser trip endet abrupt
[Musik]
der airbag rettete man wahrscheinlich
das leben immerhin draußen wartete schon
die polizei auf
[Musik]
nach brasilien wo fußballspieler ware
götter sind
radfahrer stehen weiter unten in der
hackordnung wie dieses video zeigt
erst holen die kids ihn vom rad und
hauen dann damit ab na dann gute fahrt
[Musik]
er hat kein herz für tiere sie leben uns
bedingungslos sind unsere treuesten
freunde
[Musik]
ach wie süß bei solchen anblicken
schlagen unsere herzen höher
[Musik]
und erst recht wenn sie uns auf der
straße vor die karre laufen
[Musik]
oder neben uns her ist dass ein wolf
jetzt wird der bock zum gärtner auf dem
land geht alles seinen gang gemächlicher
hier hat die natur das sagen wenn sie
mal in einer schafherde stecken bleiben
am besten zurücklehnen und schäfchen
zählen
[Musik]
ach wie süß alle meine entchen
händchen
das ist ein erpel und er ist sauer
unglaublich sie es fast auf mich los
wir fanden es lustig
trotz nieselregens machen mama giraffe
und tochter giraffe ihren täglichen
spaziergang sohn giraffe will
aufschliessen zu hektisch die pace jungs
[Musik]
noch ein paar schwarze schafe auf eis
in manchester hat dieser schwan seine
berufung gefunden
jetzt bringe ich mal ordnung in den
straßenverkehr
eines lernen die autofahrer an diesem
montagmorgen
geduld
in unserer sendung betonen wir immer
wieder wie wichtig es ist die
verkehrsregeln zu beachten
dieses bewusstsein würden wir unseren
zuschauern so gerne mit auf den weg
geben bei katzen haben wir schon erfolg
hier der beweis
sehr gut
[Musik]
kennen sie den film die reise der
pinguine
hier sehen sie die hauptdarsteller nach
abschluss der dreharbeiten
es geht zurück in die antarktis
[Musik]
offenbar hat dieser pinguin auf der
abschiedsparty zu sehr krachen lassen
aber film stars finden immer jemanden
der ihnen wieder auf die beine helfen
[Musik]
die flosse
bevor die sendung vorbei ist versprechen
sie uns dass sie keine dieser dämlichen
dummheiten nachmachen
[Musik]